ja wieso man sagen wissenschaftler
machen die besucher aus jux und tollerei
einfach weil es so billig und bequem ist
[Musik]
freunde des das heute ist ein eher
spontanes video auch wenn das thema
eines ist dass sie schon länger mal
behandeln wollte nämlich tierversuche in
der biomedizinischen forschung denn ich
weiß dass auch ihr euch sehr für dieses
thema interessiert letzte woche hat
college immer ein video hochgeladen mit
dem titel the problem with the meist das
problem mit labormäusen es ist teil des
formats bruins riexinger dem karneval
der moderator oder protagonist deckt in
adams easing weit verbreitete irrtümer
auf die videos sind sehr gut produziert
kurz knackig unterhaltsam und sammeln
über die monate ja so ein paar millionen
views ich möchte das neueste video von
darwins ähnlich sehen über tierversuche
nutzen um ein erstes reaction video zu
machen
das college über video habe ich euch
natürlich unten verlinkt ihr könnt es
euch gerne zuerst anschauen das ist halt
auf englisch bruins es ist immer so
sketch artig aufgebaut und im laufe des
videos überzeugt er dem sein gegenüber
sich von einem lange glaubten oder
weitere breiteten irrtum zu
verabschieden
sein gegenüber in diesem video ist eine
junge forscherin und diese junge
forscherin spricht den kern ihr tun
dieser folge aus nämlich windows-taste
manroland system als du in aktion mensch
wie jeder weiß dass maus experimente
oder experiment mit nagetieren praktisch
dasselbe sind wie klinische studien an
menschen fürs tv es gibt kein
wissenschaftler auf diesem planeten der
glaubt dass maus experimente
gleichzusetzen wären mit experimenten an
menschen
ich weiß noch nicht mal ob es
irgendeinen nicht wissenschaftler gibt
der das glaubt das heißt die folge fängt
schon mal damit an dass die kommission
dass dieser weit verbreiteten irrtum
völlig übertrieben dargestellt wird was
ich schon mal von vornherein schade
finde ich find's einfach schädlich auch
nur zu suggerieren dass wissenschaftler
im labor seien sie noch so jung und
unerfahren nicht wüssten warum sie mit
mäusen arbeit wir haben genug probleme
mit misstrauen in die wissenschaft und
so fangen die probleme an
luki machen wir weiter er dem erklärt
das 95
der versuchstiere in der
biomedizinischen forschung mäuse sind
dann fährt er fort mäuse seien
allerdings denkbar schlechte
versuchstiere denn über 80 prozent der
versuche den mäusen funktionieren
funktionierenden menschen nicht mehr
das wird jetzt hier visualisierten geld
schreddern die entwicklungskosten für
neue medikamente werden dadurch sehr
hoch unterm strich heißt das für uns
weniger neue medikamente oder
medikamente die wird leisten können
wir nehmen noch ein fakt hin zu dem
video angesprochen wird nämlich dass
läuse zwar zu 97% dieselbe dna haben die
menschen aber diese drei prozent
unterschied machen einen großen
unterschied physiologisch fassen wir
erst mal zusammen was bisher in dem
video gesagt wurde die meisten versuche
in der biomedizinischen forschung werden
an mäusen gemacht ja das stimmt nur
einen teil der vorklinischen studien
lassen sich auch auf die klinischen
studien mit den menschen übertragen ja
auch das stimmt leider
die entwicklungskosten für medikamente
sind erschreckend hoch auch das stimmt
leider
und all das ist ein problem auch das
stimmt
okay machen wir weiter mit dem
eigentlichen problematischen teil dieses
videos die junge forscherin ist ganz
entsetzt über die neuen erkennen ist und
fragt sich ja aber warum machen wir dann
so viele maus versuche wenn die doch so
problematisch sind und hier kommt adams
antwort ich glaube ich schon direkt an
dem wort können die nicht okay können
wir und heißt soviel wie praktisch oder
geeignet aber das heißt auch so viel wie
bequem angenehm dass das ganze
impliziert dass forscher out of
convenience auto schier comedians
methoden bevorzugt das ist natürlich
quatsch es geht hier nicht um
convenience es geht hier vielmehr um um
stability und fiese bild also wie
geeignet sind diese methode diese
modelle und können wir das umsetzen
irgendwie weit können wir das über
umsätzen mit den ressourcen die wir
haben in irgend bestimmten labor und
dieser unschöne neben geschmack der
durch das wort convenience hier
mitschwingt der festigt sich jetzt im
folgenden teil von dem video entfernt
nämlich vor zu erklären dass mäuse im
vergleich zu anderen
justieren ein schnäppchen sind der fakt
stimmt was mich stört ist dass zu keinem
zeitpunkt erwähnt wird
wie teuer die besucher an sich
eigentlich sind wenn wir von convenience
sprechen dann sind zell versuche in
petrischalen viel mehr kombinieren
zellen zu züchten ist viel weniger
aufwand als tiere zu züchten die modelle
zu entwickeln die tiere zu halten
die räumlichkeiten dafür zu haben die
tiere zu pflegen ok adams zweiter punkt
kommt geht mehr auf die convenience ein
er sagt dass mäuse unglaublich leicht
genetisch modifizierbar sind ja häufig
ohne immunsysteme man sieht ihm dunkeln
leuchten mäuse und extra tumor und das
stimmt alles
ich krieg hier so ein leichten märz
island ist frankenstein weib ich muss
sagen es ist arbeit ich ja es ist
abartig dass wir müsen tumore verpassen
die frage ist nur wenn ich keine tumore
aus habe wie zum teufel will ich dann
ein tumor untersuchen wenn ich in einem
anderen tier oder in einem menschen ich
finde dass sich die sendung hier fast
schon ein bisschen widerspricht weil am
anfang wurde dazu noch erklärt dass
mäuse denkbar schlechte modelle sind
weil sie so wenig mit menschen zu tun
haben
hier wird jetzt als absurdität
dargestellt in welchen farben und formen
und genetischen veränderungen mäuse
daher kommen dabei ist das ja genau der
grund warum diese ebenso wichtige model
das sind eben weil man sie genetisch so
variieren kann ihm weiß neuse gibt ohne
immunsystem wo minimum krankheiten
testen kann
diese abartigkeit ist ja gleichzeitig
auch das wo das medizinische potenzial
liegt so dieses matches fragen steinbild
wie es weiter gesponnen er dem erwähnt
nämlich als nächstes den animal welfare
act das ist ein gesetz das in den usa
1966 verabschiedet wurde um tiere zu
schützen im bereich research &
exhibition labormäuse und laborratten
sind von diesem tierschutzgesetz
ausgenommen das kommt jetzt natürlich
erst mal ziemlich grausam und
unterstrichen wir das ganze noch von
einer maus die auf einem mini elektro
stuhl sitzt und die forschen sagt dazu
wie gehen die wissenschaftler jetzt hier
so kaltblütig und grausamen darzustellen
fehle schon mal prinzipiell
problematisch zweitens implizit das
ganze hier das forsche mit labormäusen
so grausam umgehen können wie sie wollen
ohne irgendwelche konsequenzen davon zu
tragen ohne dass sich irgendjemand auch
umgekehrt wissen die ihren geht und das
stimmt nicht nur weil in den usa die
more labormäuse nicht unter den ende mai
will für act fall heißt es nicht dass
sie völlig unreguliert sind im gegenteil
die versuche während extrem streng
reguliert jeder tiefes reihe muss
individuell beantragt werden und jeder
antrag wird von einer kommission
begutachtet und über jedem individuellen
versuch stehen laien in die sogenannten
free press videos und rief ein zu
deutsch vermeiden verringern verbessern
da sind die leitlinien die
wissenschaftler sind dazu verpflichtet
tierversuche womöglich zu vermeiden und
zu verringern außerdem sind die
wissenschaftler dazu verpflichtet rief
ein
ihre experimente so zu verbessern dass
die tiere möglichst wenig leiden zum
beispiel möglichst wenig schmerzen
allein oder andere art und weise leiden
natürlich gibt es auch externe
einrichtungen welche die
forschungseinrichtungen da überprüfen
und ihnen auf die finger schauen und
auch schauen ob alles richtig gemacht
wird übrigens freue mich dass auch immer
sehr viele leute fragen ob tierversuche
auch in kosmetikartikeln getestet werden
mehr seit mir jetzt 2013 kann man
europaweit keine kosmetikartikeln wir
kaufen die an tieren getestet wurden es
ist ein verbot
und natürlich ist auch das testen an
tieren ebenso verboten
zurück zur biomedizinischen forschung
über die frage ist doch wenn wir keine
böse hätten
was ist die alternative um krebs zu
untersuchen
und hier kommen wir so langsam zu den
grundlegenden problem dieses videos also
m holte experten dazu professorin dr
esra raser ich habe nachgeschaut sie
forschen leukämie sie spricht sich
öffentlich dagegen aus dass die
biomedizinische forschung
sehr auf mausmodelle fokussiert ist
prinzipiell fürchten dass du zu sehen
nur was sie hier in diesem video als
alternative vorschlägt ist mehr als nur
mal sie sagt anstatt mordversuche zu
machen sollte man sich einfach auf die
untersuchung menschlicher krebszellen
konzentrieren
also erstens wir das natürlich gemacht
natürlich untersucht man menschliche
krebszellen diese experimente nennt man
in vitro experimente also im reagenzglas
in fast allen bio medizinischen studien
gibt es sowohl in vitro als auch in
libro daten in vivo sind dann die
experimente an lebenden organismus
meistens meuser jedes modell hat so
seine vor und nachteile natürlich
während menschliche krebszellen ja schon
mal menschlich sind
es halten sich ein paar krebszellen im
labor natürlich natürlich anders als ein
tumor in einem lebenden organismus in
einem menschlichen körper und natürlich
kann ich auch nicht die folgen die ein
anti tumor medikamente auf meinen ganzen
körper art anhand von paar tumorzellen
oder ein bisschen tumorgewebe in meiner
kirche schale festmachen das ist völlig
klar
und genauso ist es klar nämlich wie
gesagt jedem wissenschaftler klar dass
eine maus nicht dasselbe ist wie ein
mensch
es gibt hier auch human heißt meist also
mäusen denen menschliche zellen oder
menschen die hygiene eingesetzt wurden
damit sie ihr einen menschlichen
organismus allen und selbst die sich
human ist meist das weiß jeder können
natürlich niemals klinische studien oder
tests an menschen ersetzen diese ganzen
in vitro tests computer simulation alle
methoden die es gibt jede für sich
genauso wie der maus versuch selbst
alles sind nur modelle die ihre grenzen
haben
ich weiß jetzt als chemikerin
computersimulation sind gerade der heiße
steht in der chemie also der versuch
reaktionsmechanismen durch berechnungen
vorauszusagen so dass man nicht mehr
alles im labor ausprobieren muss das
würde auch sehr viel geld sparen und
selbst das selbst der reaktion zwischen
zwei molekülen oder zwingende molekül
und einem protein sind so kompliziert zu
modellieren geschweige denn ein ganzer
fucking organismus mit allem was
dazugehört da sind wir doch wer sie
sehr sehr weit von entfernt alle diese
methoden kann man natürlich kombinieren
die können sich ergänzen damit wir so
etwas komplexes wie zum beispiel ein
tumor in einem lebenden organismus
hinreichend irgendwie beschreiben können
nur zu behaupten dass wissenschaftler
mäuse typen weiß halt so billig und
kombiniert ist obwohl es ja mit
menschlichen krebszellen genauso gut
oder besser ginge das stimmt einfach
nicht also die probleme in der
medikamentenentwicklung wurden in diesem
video eigentlich schon ganz gut benannt
ich finde es nur schade wie die fakten
hier interpretiert wurden und man es
zieht hier ganz schön dass es in der
wissenschaft nie nur um die fakten
alleine geht es gibt immer immer um den
kontext und darum wie wir die fakten
interpretieren selbst die quellen die in
diesem video genannt werden es werden
hier einige quellen zitiert sind meiner
meinung nach teilweise falsch zitiert
weil vielleicht einzelne fakten aus der
quelle rausgenommen werden aber nicht
die hauptmesse dieser quelle zum
beispiel wurde hier ein kommentar
artikel von steve perlman zitiert der
2014 in nature erschienen in diesem
kommentar geht es aber gar nicht herum
das haus für quatsch sind der autor
kritisiert stattdessen das allgemeine
experimenten design der vorklinischen
studien also kurz gesagt die maus
versuche müssen besser wären nicht
abgeschafft werden sie müssen besser
werden die probleme des ganzen sind
völlig klar die erfolgsrate von der
entwicklung eines medikaments im labor
von der chemischen synthese bis hin zur
anwendung in patienten die erfolgsrate
ist viel zu klein ist erschreckend klein
die zeit die die entwicklung dort ist
erschreckend lang und die kosten die da
reingeht sind erschreckend groß aber
eins ist fakt
der fiktive suche jetzt hier raus nehmen
würden dann werden die erfolgsraten noch
kleiner es für mehr menschen zu schaden
kommen und es wäre auf jeden fall noch
teurer denn die klinischen studien ist
das was richtig teuer ist ist es ethisch
total vertretbar wenn man sagt alle
leben dieser welt haben für mich den
selben wert einmal ein mäuse leben hat
für mich genauso viel wert wie ein
und genauso viel wie ein menschenleben
wenn ich davon überzeugt bin dann sage
wenn wir medikamente für menschen
entwickelt da sollten wir diese auch an
menschen testen
dann ist das eine konsequente logische
denkweise ich vertrete eine andere
meinung ich vertrete die meinung dass
tierversuche das kleinere übel sind mit
dem ziel menschen leben zu halten
jetzt erstmal danke dass ihr das video
bis hierhin geschaut habt ich habe jetzt
auch nur die oberfläche des ganzen
problems an kratzen können in diesem
video last weiter offen darüber
diskutieren wir sind hier um dinge zu
verstehen und nicht um uns gegenseitig
die köpfe einzuschlagen schreibt mir
eure fragen und anmerkungen die
kommentare ich werde sie lesen ich werde
versuchen und hier und da auch mal zu
antworten wir sehen uns nächste woche
bleibt sicher